[Music]
huh
[Music]
well this is the place
where there's smoke there's
hey the how you holding up
been better i know
probably not hard to tell
so what happened needed someone to talk
to
uh-huh first take a look
hello my name is arif iqbal and this is
wns news
today's story a routine roadside
inspection led the ncpd to the trail of
a dangerous abductor and murderer
the incident occurred at the
intersection of 7th and 15th avenue
the following police footage was
captured at the scene
10 38 i repeat at 10 38 registration 208
6244 we're exiting our vehicle now
copy that out of the car hands up
easy officer relax
shut your mouth oh [ __ ] uh
we have a 10 53 and a 10 54. i repeat a
10 53 and 10 54.
the boy from the footage is lavar
martinez
age 17. his parents reported his
disappearance over a month ago
unfortunately levar's life could not be
saved
his body could not withstand the severe
septic shock he suffered
reports revealed the teenager was given
dangerously high levels of hormones
anabolic steroids and stimulants the
possessions and genetic material
of seven other missing teens were also
found in the car
belonging to one anthony harris
unfortunately their fates remain unknown
although the criminal widely known as
peter pan survived the gunshot
he has not regained consciousness what's
the problem if they caught the guy
my nephew stay tuned randy
disappeared not long past and what you
just saw
the kid was wearing randy's shoes ah
jesus
randy's disappearance you know anything
else
my sister and i don't get along that
well
i don't know much just wish i could have
been there for her when she needed it
most
and what they figured you'd get
emotional and kept you off the case
more like a restraining order won't let
me anywhere near it
gonogl took the lead on it lazy ass gunk
and so far he ain't accomplished [ __ ]
no way i'd let this lie i know
and that's why i'm asking for your help
so what do we need to do
can't interrogate the guy because he's a
veg but
we can view his dreams i'm sorry dreams
you heard me come on i'll explain on the
way
it's an experimental procedure but it's
already yielding results
they record dreams that can be played
back as bds
you got access to these dreams not yet
but they keep them in the lab we're
headed to now
make sure
okay got an appointment not exactly
we'll go in together but uh
not through the main entrance oh we're
gonna break the law
we'll find a different way in and then
hustle out quick
never actually been here so i'll need
your help
[Music]
is it true what they say
[Music]
great but now we find our
entrance they have an audit today should
be a ghost town
how did you know about the audit i did
my homework
know where they're keeping the bd i'm
likely the room worthy
should be labeled as anthony harris
a few of these rooms we probably don't
have to bother with
locked can't get in
nothing here no sign of any pd's
so
got some kind of
empty brain dance case
so
oh
[Music]
recommended
no
hey river i think i got it
found something not yet anthony harris
let's try these drawers
say river why not just have a janitor
crack a door for you
can't risk getting scalded for sniffing
around somebody else's
face yo what are you doing here
you got kicked off the force just
suspended
actually
i'm calling the actual police oh wait
wait wait here
hear me out please seriously river
you weren't in enough trouble already
harris kidnapped
my nephew
i'm sorry really i am but we store
evidence here and we have strict
protocols
protocols talking about his nephew's
life here
at child's life this is an
ongoing police investigation go
please
get out now listen you work with badges
right
you know what they're like freedom
analysis they'll [ __ ] out failure
this type of thinking is the very reason
we live in a lawless city
lawless
remember your first med school exam
you know the one passed it with flying
colors
gotta remember it ladies room erupted in
flame
they evacuated everybody for two hours
i cannot believe you would throw that in
my face
i never wish to see you here again
especially you
you don't know him well do you this man
is a bastard
river and i get along we're friends
hasn't let me down yet
oh i thought us frets too is that why
you're refusing to help him out
harris's dream beatty where is he
he isn't dreaming what
why
a bullet damaged his cerebral cortex we
get only dissonant urges
pieces
i'd like for audio-visual stimulation
but he isn't on the spectrum a favorite
song or movie helps you reach the kids
might be worth a try
i am aware of the similarity
hypothalamus stimulation and hormone
production
but harris is not a child i have never
tried the procedure on an adult
any reason you haven't because unlike
river i went to med school and studied
neuroscience
and not by reading about it over
someone's shoulder on the metro
let's try it we don't even know his
preferences
i'll find something that mean you're
willing to try
just go i'll open the front door for you
let's ride v i know exactly where to
start
say by the way what do you know about
biochips
arasaka's relic in particular
well it's designed to store a person's
neural engram oh
sorry just imagine copying over a
person's memories and personality right
i get that
more curious what happens if the stored
engram overwrites the engrams of the
chip carrier
over right i i'm not even sure that's
possible
why do you ask nah never mind
not a big deal thanks
oh
oh
for protection
is
okay let me hear it
so got booted off the force uh
suspended mayer's death stank to high
heaven
inquest into kicked under the rug so
i made a fuss not worth asking how you
feel about that
nope
it's just uh it's not easy for me to
talk about what's biting in my ass
fair enough could tell me where we're
headed though
to josh's randy's mom
she thinks he just ran away from home
for now keep the kidnapping between us
gonna tell me why we aren't trying to
find harris's apartment
that's a house i doubt he's keeping his
victims in his basement
besides we are trying i want to see if
we can find some connection to harris at
randy's
pretty weak lead best we can hope for
just now
not worried yahwen's gonna toe the line
right you add to her superiors
used to be friends thought she'd do that
plus not that i'd use it but i do know
one skeleton she'd prefer remain tucked
in her closet
you think y'all want to actually help us
all things considered
yeah these tips of ours always end up
the same way
i'll tell you about it over a beer
sometime
really ought to focus on finding randy
now
of course
[Music]
sure been a while needs to come over
every weekend
and changed it all since places like
this never change
lovely neighborhood
river you either got business with me or
news about my randy
wouldn't drag your butt out here if you
didn't joss
meet v
sophie is this about my randy
randy's been taken
why didn't you call josh i
threw a blanket over truth like always
police caught the guy but he caught a
bullet and he's in a coma
being watched but where's randy
we're looking joss here
listen we need to look through randy's
things
why to find any lead we can
trust me joss just don't destroy
anything
randy doesn't like you when anyone pucks
through his stuff
let's go v the kids are playing outside
tell him it's time to eat
what's on your mind i think it's good
she learned the truth
that's the trailer eyes peeled for
details eh
uncle river
monique dorian hey guys
is this your partner just a friend
you're gonna stay over we'll see
your mom's waiting for you with dinner
this is their old trailer randy moved in
when i bought him a new one
real hellhole like in my good old days
you check around i'll check the trash
[Music]
jason can still see the knicks from
those first
years we measured the kids
left his favorite hoodie in the closet
locked know where the key might be nope
expensive tech randy had the scratch for
this
you're joking
no chance randy could afford hardware
like this
way too pricey we gotta get in
i doubt anyone knows the password can
you crack it
tainted overlord favorite band
you know he used to send him an album
every year for his b day
drugs let's not go there
society's fault
got some kind of key here real fossil
not quite what we're looking for no
some kind of game here shipping code on
it
let's move let's go
don't know how river damn
need to try to guess it then what could
he have
who's the girl his ex natalie
eggs and the pig what's her name natalie
gonna have to keep trying
librium arbitrium dark [ __ ]
sound could use work but you can tell
they put blood sweat and tears into it
he randy looks like his tag
punch this track title librum arbitrium
that did it help me have a look around
something deeply [ __ ] about that
cartoon
my skin's crawling
so
if they caught harrison if you collect
that
located street [ __ ] river i remember
that day
he lives close to an old school
true angel of empathy this guy huh
figured out randy's identity sending the
game as a present
the one you found in his drawer the same
shipping code suggests the prick scented
from the badlands
this guy baited randy like a pro
river do you
are you seeing what i'm seeing no
there's no way why would he do that
not only did they agree to meet but it
looks like randy was as excited as any
kid on his way to a theme park
[ __ ] this creep definitely scrambled
randy's head
natalie must have been the only person
randy trusted
can we view this page with a link
some kind of link the one randy wrote
about
let's find out
a hidden page set up by anthony harris
christ i'm gonna be sick
[Music]
jesus river this is [ __ ] guy preyed on
troubled kids
made habit to target boys like randy
this is my fault
if i just paid more attention just
talked with him more
hey come on you're not the one to blame
here
there was a file here deleted looks like
but the name's still
[Music]
it there the video file on randy's comp
called something like that
hey look the name of this cartoon
matches the missing file on harris's
page
that's what we needed to find for yawin
v we've got it
randy must have downloaded it sure but v
don't you get it this could be the key
to harris's mind
here's hoping hey uh
can you use any of that netrunner magic
to shake anything else out of this
[Music]
so
not that kind of magician
okay we'll have to manage without it
that cartoon river
could be what we've been looking for you
said yourself we needed something to get
harris to dream
send it to yarwin right sending it now
okay says she'll get back to me by
morning
and that i am a son of a [ __ ]
and uh come on
let's grab a bite
[Music]
[Music]
listen let's not worry joss more than we
need to huh
we're hot on the trail we'll know more
tomorrow
that's it
dorian please but it really tastes like
booger
joss we're finished
well done off to bed then
we left some for you uncle river thanks
monique
tell me you found something
looks like randy knew his kidnapper they
were in touch
why would he do something like that you
know him
kids look for help in the wrong places
when's the last time you ate yesterday
have mine i'm not hungry
thanks maybe later
now you no [ __ ] don't look at my
brother just tell me
will you find my boy
river's a hell of an investigator
randy's as good as found
won't give up until i do joss
joss you mind if he takes randy's
trailer for the night
no sure
stay in right you gotta help me see this
through
to the end
of course i'll stay find your way all
right
yup gonna hit the sack soon
can't be easy raising three kids on your
own
well it wasn't any easier with my
husband
in fact the best days were when he
didn't come home
there were times i wished he'd disappear
for a month just to not have him hang
around
how'd he die theo dicaldo's told me
he died an honorable death whatever the
hell that means
they showed me his body where his face
used to be
couldn't see the honor in that
that bad huh this bike in the highway
that was his world but at home
let me tell you a story
this one time he took dorian into the
city had some errand to run just
father and son he came back that night
dead ass drunk raging at me for calling
the cops on him
did you river found him in some dive and
brought dorian home
must have been a relief then when he
left
for weeks i cried every night
my husband was killed the father of my
children
um i'm sorry
randy changed he locked up not to
mention the other two i still had to
raise
life was rough with him and without him
sometimes there's no solution
v wake up
ah not done sleeping
y'all went called it worked the cartoon
he's dreaming you you got the bd
right here slotted in jack into the
computer i want to see it on the monitor
that dock of yours is quick not bad
[Music]
what's the matter with you anthony i
have to report this
i hope you understand that
this isn't normal behavior
anthony you killed liam's turtle
he was sick he wouldn't eat stayed in
his shell i just wanted to help him
why injecting him with hgh
what were you thinking is this something
about you good people
your friends
[Music]
i recognize this shooting it was a case
study back at the academy
give me a sec to check which school that
was laguna bend
looks like the whole town got flooded in
the 50s well
at least we know the general area where
harris lived guess that'd be that
[Music]
so
trophy old one dated from 2042
first place in an interscholastic
wrestling tournament
don't you dare talk about my dad
shut up shut up you can't [ __ ] up
and he he was sick i just want to help
him
coming
harris looks even younger here come here
see that cow's sick like the rest
coming
[Music]
looks like a cattle bioscanner for
checking vitals
come on
[Music]
how to leave
[Music]
oh
injectors for hormones antibiotics
people ate meat loaded with the [ __ ]
part two
[Music]
supplements in the feed for disease-free
livestock
[ __ ] off
[Music]
so
ah that's our cartoon
i guess that'd be that
[Applause]
i think this might be the place fee it's
a recent memory
got a clock an hour to midnight
[Music]
looks like peter pan turned his farm
into a goddamn final bastion
[Music]
you must have been in auto shop or
something here at some point
hearing what i'm hearing trash barge
that's the signal to dump has to be a
landfill nearby
[ __ ] me he treats the kidnapped boys
like cattle
look another one
fire department search stamp right here
city south
perfect
i don't see randy anywhere
the terminal controls depends got to be
another deck somewhere for the mines and
turrets
signage on the farm model points to
petrochem
machine controls an injection system for
stimulants hormones something
hurry up
to mike hey
the illuminated towers promoting the us
cracks album that came out then
colors changed every hour i think that
might be it
okay so where do we sit now exactly
we know harris still lives near an old
school that's now underwater
you can see the nc skyline and the us
cracks towers from the farm
it's a few miles out farms located near
a landfill
we know that too
shipping code on the game randy got from
harris traces out to the badlands
those towers promoting the us cracks
album colors change regularly
once an hour so we know the time 11 at
night
right and that puts the farm east of the
city southeast actually
stamp on the ncfd certificate was from
the southern region
farm models of petrochem design so that
eliminates any others
which narrows it down to edgewood farm
that's got to be our place
so we've got it just hope we didn't [ __ ]
it up
come on we gotta go
[Music]
[Music]
damn it let this work
don't get distracted got to focus on the
road
easy for you to sing that's my nephew
out there
we'll find him river
i'd only known sooner how he felt what
was eating at him
this isn't your fault a miss uncle
and i wasn't there for him
[Music]
[ __ ]
hold on randy please hold on
grab something
river this is the farm we got it i know
let's get to the barn quick
[Music]
river this is the farm we got it i know
let's get to the barn quick
heads up turrets are live the system
controlling it must be in the house
[Music]
[Music]
river this is the farm we got it i know
let's get to the barn quick
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
so
hmm
he's gotta be here have a look around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by the bar two more turrets that front
gate's a deathtrap
damn it i'm locked up tight find enough
river come here quick
oh [ __ ]
he's here randy
he's hanging in there we make it shut
down the machine
can't unlink randy otherwise randy
1052 i repeat i've got a 10.52 at a farm
south of the city
yes you're the [ __ ] squad yeah we're
laying quartets now
no several at least do it quick damn it
oh and watch for automated defenses
hurry gotta shut it off
okay i'll disconnect it
check the other could still be alive
right
so
live whoa oh easy there easy now
hey you're all right now
been dead a few days already
it's okay don't be scared we're here to
help
you're a bit dehydrated but you're going
to be fine
help me with randy
i need to loosen this help me
[Music]
we did it river yep we sure did
but i'm not about to leave it like this
the horror of that bastard inflicted
can't let it go
he's in a coma in police custody he's
not getting away with anything
he's still alive so in a sense he is
getting away with it
not for long though
i'm gonna squeeze the life out of him
with my bare hands
come on man it won't change anything
anthony harris is a sad sack of meat
hooked up to a respirator now
for how he has to die
it's the only way i'll be sure stop
going to throw your life away getting
revenge on a brain dead vegetable
well i don't know maybe you're right
but it's driving me crazy not doing
anything
actually got quite a bit you can do
river
joss randy the kids they're gonna need
you now
more than ever yeah
no you're right
forget about harris take one day at a
time
but rest first once your head's on
straight again
give me a hollow we'll talk yeah
need a little tiny myself now but then
i'll call you
i will hey we're ready for evac are you
riding along or not
really fee thanks couldn't have done it
without you
no problem hey don't be a stranger
you